[This tape was duplicated from a 16mm original
by Colorlab for the National Library of Medicine, August 2004, NLM call number HF 783]
[Numbers flash by, counting down.]
[National Motion Pictures Co. presents Your
Health Department, Copyright MCMXLI]
[Narrator reading from a bas relief:] "The
health of the people is really the foundation
upon which all their happiness and all their
powers as a state depend."
[Building with "Board of Health" engraved above entrance.]
[Narrator:] Did you ever stop to realize how
much all these health activities mean in your life?
Let's take a look at the Browns. A typical
family whose life and whose problems are not
so very different from your own.
From the very beginning of Frank and Helen
Brown's wedded life, their health department
has been helping them achieve the blessings
of health and making theirs
a more healthful community.
Before they could obtain a marriage license
in the state where they lived, they had to
show that they were free from venereal infection,
an important factor in their future happiness
and in the health of any children who might
be born unto them.
The doctor draws a sample of blood for a test.
This should be made a routine part of every
physical examination and must bring to light
many unsuspected cases of syphilis.
In the health department laboratory, the blood
samples submitted by the doctor are tested.
At the completion of this test, Frank Brown's sample will show up negative, no syphilis,
but the man who followed him into the doctor's
office has a positive test. This means he
has syphilis and requires prompt treatment.
Early continuous treatment will cure syphilis
and prevent its further spread.
[A person receives an injection in the arm.]
Why does the health department come in on
this? It wants to find the contacts of the
infected man and see that they undergo treatment
if it is necessary.
Since continuity of treatment is so essential
for cure, the health authorities are also
vitally interested in seeing that those under
treatment keep it up until a cure is effected.
When their first baby was expected, Mrs. Brown
underwent a blood test as part of her prenatal
examination. Why? Because treatment of expectant
mothers who have syphilis will prevent their
babies being born with this disease.
Together with other expectant mothers, Mrs.
Brown had the benefit of valuable instruction
given by a competent health nurse.
[A nurse stands before a class of students, writing on a chalkboard and pointing to charts on the wall.]
At home, too, Mrs. Brown found the public
health nurse most helpful. This work was carried
on in complete cooperation with their private
physician.
Their first baby was born at home, and the
physician called to engage a maternity nurse
to assist at delivery, a service offered by
many health departments.
The nurse helps to prepare for any emergency.
Warming beds or baby incubators must be available
in case the newborn babe is premature.
Ready at a moment's notice, the maternity
nurse answers the call, happy in the knowledge
that she has guided the expectant mother in
healthful living and has helped her prepare
for a safe delivery and a happy convalescence.
[A nurse carrying her bag of medical supplies emerges from a car and walks up the steps of the house.]
Doing fine, thanks. Each year thousands of
mothers and babies benefit by this maternity
service. Does health work pay? What do you think?
Getting the facts needed for baby's birth
registration.
These people are going to a lot of trouble
to obtain birth certificates, which they must
have for employment or for many other reasons.
The proper registration of births is of importance to prevent future difficulties.
Along with other records, these birth records comprise the vital statistics which serve
as a guide to health workers, showing them
where they need to put the most effort and
how successful their work has been.
[Bar graph with title "Tuberculosis, Deaths
in Five Indiana Counties."
The health department's work was not completed when the baby was born.
It carries through after the birth of the baby. Our suspicion is aroused by a persistent hacking cough.
The nurse makes some inquires which lead her
to believe an examination for tuberculosis
is in order.
[Medical form stating "grandmother died of tuberculosis" is shown.]
[A nurse is shown interviewing a woman, then the woman is in a physician's office being guided to an x-ray machine.]
The doctor's thorough examination, which includes
the x-ray, reveals an active case of tuberculosis.
Thus, possible infection of the Browns' baby
was prevented and the woman received the treatment
she needed, all because of the thoroughness
of observing and following through, which
are a part of health department training and
practice.
All the home contacts of the tubercular woman
are checked carefully.
When the baby is six months old, the nurse
reminds Mrs. Brown of the necessity of smallpox
vaccination, and immunization against diphtheria.
Surely this safe process is more sensible
than running the risk of catching these dangerous
diseases. The Browns' next door neighbors
were guilty of a terrible act of carelessness.
They failed to immunize their child against
diphtheria. One day it struck.
[A doctor tends to a child lying in bed at home.]
As soon as the doctor makes a diagnosis of
diphtheria, he gives antitoxin.
Sometimes it is necessary to take cultures
on other members of the family to control
the spread of the disease.
When a case of communicable disease is reported,
the health department comes into play once more.
It offers laboratory service to confirm
the doctor's diagnosis. It safeguards the
community by isolating the sick individual.
[A diptheria quarantine sign is tacked to the front door of a home.]
Once again the public health nurse is of invaluable
help. Here she is instructing the child's
mother on the proper technique to use in the
sickroom. This is important in controlling
the spread of the disease.
[The nurse demonstrates proper handwashing and other care and sanitary practices to the mother.]
The school, of course, is an important place
to work for prevention of spread in many communicable diseases.
[A school health staffer is shown checking a girl's throat for signs of illness.]
This work is aided by the use of sanitary
drinking fountains such as these and by rigid
inspection of the entire sanitary system.
The school has more than a preventive role to play.
It is also an ideal place for teaching the
positive lessons of health.
Not only by classroom instruction, but by every tried means at its command does the health education department
endeavor to guide the people in the paths
of healthful living.
It is not sufficient for science to learn
new facts about nutrition. These facts must
be brought home to us so that we will learn
how to make use of them in our daily lives.
Since many health faults need correction before
a child is of school age, pre-school examinations,
dental as well as medical, are of great importance.
The school is a good place to develop a physical
education program,
which will build strong bodies for our children.
[End of Part One]
[Clicking, sputtering sounds.]
[Part Two]
[Numbers flash by, counting down.]
But to return to our friends, the Browns,
the milk they drink, so essential in a healthful
diet, must be safe milk, carefully guarded
from contamination in every step of its handling
from the producer to the consumer.
Healthy cows tested to show they are free
from tuberculosis, mastitis, and contagious
abortion. Scrupulous cleanliness of the dairy
barn, the cows and the milker's hands. Rinsing
of udders with bactericidal solution.
[Man is shown with buckets of liquid, cleaning the cow's udders.
The inspector makes a thorough check of the
milk house also. Adequate hand-washing facilities.
A stove to heat water for washing and sterilizing
cans and buckets. Check.
Clean milk aprons. Check.
Cabinet for storing strainer pads, chemical
disinfectant, and other loose equipment.
Water for cooling milk down to a safe temperature.
Clean buckets and cans. Check.
Milk produced under these conditions is clean
milk, but as a further safeguard, it must
be pasteurized.
When the milk reaches the pasteurization plant,
it is dumped in properly covered receiving
vats and sampled for tests checking the effectiveness
of the sanitary methods employed in production.
From the receiving tank the milk is transferred
through sanitary piping to the pasteurizer,
which is equipped with leak-proof inlet and
outlet valves. Each pasteurizer has indicating,
recording, and air space thermometers.
After each day's operation, all equipment which
comes in contact with the milk must be disassembled,
washed and placed upon racks where it remains
for inspection.
Immediately after being used it is assembled
and sterilized. Dump tanks, filters, pasteurizers,
sanitary pipes, coolers, bottlers, and individual
bottles must be kept scrupulously clean.
Samples of the producer's milk is analyzed
microscopically by using the breed microscopic technique.]
[A man works with containers and pipettes at a laboratory bench, testing samples.]
The effectiveness of cooling, the cleanliness
of utensils, and the presence of mastitis
can be determined by this test.
[A man peers through a microscope, analyzing a sample.]
After being pasteurized a bacterial plate
count is made of the finished product.
At this time a phosphotase test is made to determine
the efficiency of pasteurization.
The results of the foregoing precaution in
producing, handling, and processing milk is
grade A pasteurized milk. When the Browns
eat in a restaurant, their health is safeguarded
by sanitary inspection. Here is a sanitary
inspector checking on dishwashing equipment.
Pure water is always an important health problem,
but the Browns don't have to worry about that
because their water comes from the municipal
plant which is subject to constant inspection...
[An inspector examines equipment at a water treatment facility.]
But, the people who live out in the country
must obtain their water from their own wells.
Properly constructed and located, they are
safe, but many a case of typhoid has been
traced back to a polluted well caused by a cracked platform, split base, and no stuffing box.
The spout is flamed to destroy bacteria and
a sample is collected in a sterilized bottle
which may be obtained from an approved laboratory.
Tested in the health department's water laboratory...
[A man in a lab coat tests small bottles containing water samples, drawing up water into a pipette and distributing droplets into a tray.]
...the water proves to be highly polluted
with colon bacteria, an indication of possible
typhoid contamination.
[A sign reading "Danger, Unfit to Drink" is placed in front of a water pump.]
Advice on well construction and location is
available to you for the asking. Simply write
your health department. Another function of
the health department is the inspection of
swimming pools.
The Browns have a further advantage over their
rural neighbors in the disposal of human waste.
That problem is taken care of for them by
a municipal sewage disposal plant, which renders
these wastes non- injurious to health.
Where water under pressure is not available;
it is impractical to build a septic tank.
The best solution is a sanitary toilet built
according to health department specification.
In order to combat those diseases which are
waterborne, the sanitary engineer also works
toward the prevention of stream pollution.
In still another way is his Health Department
interested in Frank Brown's health.
Aroused by a case of silicosis, which occurred
in a fellow worker of his...
...the director of industrial hygiene sends
his inspector to the plant where Frank works
to collect dust samples.
And, the industrial hygiene laboratory proves
the existence of health hazards
which must be eliminated.
A still further service of the health department
is the distribution of certain drugs, vaccines,
and serum to doctors for use on those who
cannot afford to pay for them. Thus, no one
need be denied the benefits of modern medicine.
Fortunate, indeed, are the Browns to have
this intensive health protection once available
only to city dwellers.
For the families that dwell in the great rural
areas, or along the shaded main streets of
our small towns, adequate full-time health
work has not existed for so very long. In
many areas, it does not exist yet.
Even though this is an age of speed, distances
in the country are too great for health activity
to be carried out with maximum effectiveness
from a central location
such as the health department.
To accomplish the most good, health activity
must be localized. It must serve the people
of one county or a few counties combined to
make a district.
Thus does it establish the intimacy and thoroughness
which ensure maximum effectiveness.
The staff of the local health department,
its director, its public health nurses,
its sanitary officers, and its clerical force
are all in health work on a full-time basis.
They have been carefully [inaudible] in the
best universities,
and through lectures, they keep up with the newest developments in their field.
Naturally, thus equipped and thus devoted,
they will do a good job of protecting the
health of the people they serve. Does organized local health work pay?
[Bar graph is displayed with title "Diphtheria:  Deaths in Five Indiana Counties."]
These figures show how deaths from certain diseases have been reduced as a result of
instituting full-time health work. Behind
these cold statistics is the story of reduction
of needless suffering and preventable death.
[Bar graph with title "Typhoid: Deaths in
Five Indiana Counties."]
You there, are you protected like the Browns
by organized local health service? If so,
cooperate with it in every way you can. If
not, who then is responsible for your community's
health? Are you getting the health protection
you ought to have?
[The End]